hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another video in the fastest mac mini on
the face of the planet earth video
series
yeah so uh if you appreciate this video
series or if you like it go ahead and
give a thumbs up on this video it really
does help us out and it'll uh get this
next episode rolling out pretty quick
either way this is going to be one of
the shorter videos in the series as it's
a pretty simple upgrade but today we're
going to be upgrading the 2011 mac minis
random access memory
yeah
so let's go ahead and get started with
this one so for this particular upgrade
there are no screwdrivers or any sort of
tools needed just the mac mini and the
16 gigabytes of ddr3 ram which can be
found at that link in the description
and possibly a supervisor to help us out
this ram here is
333 megahertz ram the fastest that this
mac mini's motherboard can handle and we
got it from other world computing as you
can see here by the way if you're
wondering about the total costs or
prices of this build we'll have that
covered in a sort of conclusive video
later but on with the ram unboxing which
was super duper easy i actually did need
a tool for this but you just open it and
bam there's the ram
that rhymed you can take the mini flip
it over and find where the dots line up
that hold the back on and you can twist
it off and have all the access to the
internal same as before and the ram
happens to be right on top so it's super
easy for us here and makes it easier
than the ssd install we did earlier
basically we can unseat both of the
pre-installed two gigabyte ram chips
just by pulling the metal brackets apart
and popping the dimms up where they can
be slid out
and you can take both of them out
leaving the slots empty and then
installing a brand new ram is equally
simple just make sure you seat the ram
first by slipping it into place and then
pushing it down until it clicks and do
that with both of your dimms and that's
it the ram is installed so you can put
the back cover back on the mini and boot
back into lion once you boot it back up
if all goes well you should be able to
go straight into os 10 and hit that
apple logo in the menu bar and click
about this mac where you can confirm
that your memory total is now 16
gigabytes and if you want further proof
that both of your eight gigabyte dimms
are working just click more info under
memory you'll have a handy dandy little
diagram for you
so there you go your 1333 megahertz
random access memory is now in full
operation boom thanks for watching this
video and in the next part we'll really
see what this machine can do so leave a
thumbs up if you want to see it sooner
either way see you next time guys peace
[Music]
you